[Music]
and so how has China got to this place
of being a sign of power well very
interesting question I think when you
need to dial back to the early days of
the People's Republic when politics and
behavior were dominated by Mao Zedong's
obsession with class struggle and this
eventually tipped the country over into
the Cultural Revolution which is best
characterized as a decade-long national
nervous breakdown
leading to extensive anarchy and more or
less total paralysis in terms of
scientific technological and
intellectual effort the only scientists
that were not rusticated during that
period were those specializing on
development of nuclear weapons you know
there that they had kind of protected
mantle thrown around them but all other
intellectuals were categorized as a
stinking ninth and sent off to you know
to till the fields and do other
demeaning and pointless work so when
China came blinking into the daylight
after the end of the Cultural Revolution
they had a lot of ground to catch up and
we're in the market for as many ideas as
they could get and it so happened that
some of China's leaders in particular
jazzy young but also dong helping
himself picked up on some of the
writings of Alvin Toffler this u.s.
futurologist who wrote books future
shock and third wave which although as
with most futurology there was a certain
amount of nonsense in it he was
remarkably prescient in terms of
identifying the implications of an
information revolution that was just
then starting to take place and I think
China's leaders in the market for any
ideas that would accelerate the economic
development programs on which they were
in bar
took to this and ident identified it
with it
very early on now you know China
obviously the Chinese leadership were
very apprehensive about the internet
because they were not slow to identify
its potential as a vector for what they
regarded as subversive ideas but they
kind of bit the bullet and they made a
series of centrally directed top-down
efforts to promote the development of
the Internet's in China and that
eventually that started out obviously
very heavily reliant on United States
technology and and commercial expertise
but there are a lot of young Chinese
engineers and scientists who had trained
in US and Western universities many done
some kind of apprenticeship in or around
Silicon Valley came back to China imbued
with all sorts of ideas and were very
quickly able to work up a range of
digital services that were uniquely well
suited to the needs of China's emerging
netizen population as it was termed you
had that you you also had extensive
government support for companies like
Huawei and at the same time of course
this became a protected sector that the
you know that foreign businesses could
only get into in a kind of ancillary way
providing technology providing know-how
but not actually doing business as as
such within China and that created a
kind of shield behind which Chinese
companies were able to evolve very
rapidly and is this sort of like a
radical change from the power of
nation-states or just a manifestation or
continuing of other forces well I mean
power is power and you know how it is
defined and how it is exercised changes
over time but if you look at previous
history the way states tended to
exercise power was through the
deliberate use of a calculated use of
military force to achieve their
objectives I think that kind of calculus
of risk if you like has changed since
people have begun to realize just how
devastating industrial and
post-industrial warfare can look like
and what I think this means is that
states are increasingly looking at other
means of exercising power and if you
look at the contest station the contest
that's taking place between the United
States and China at the moment this is a
contest that is first and foremost
playing out in the high technology and
economic arenas and you're in in China's
case they've always had this concept of
comprehensive national power the
necessity of brigade or national
capabilities in pursuit of central
government strategic directives it's
something it's very easy for
authoritarian States to do much less so
for democratic states other than in
extreme situations such as we saw during
World War two so we're seeing China very
deliberately and calculatingly brigade
in all aspects of national power in
pursuit of economic development
political influence and it must be said
military but of course military
capabilities in today's world are
increasingly cyber defendants and cyber
enable the network dependence
and we're seeing the role of what's
rather incorrectly called artificial
intelligence and autonomous systems and
robotics playing a growing role in the
future development of warfare and
China's really pushing its foot to the
floor
to achieve mastery and actually
domination in in these areas because
what's what's going to matter in all
these areas is who gets to decide what
the technical standards are going to be
that everyone else will be required to
rely upon and so it's about you know
creating standards creating control of
networks supply chains or all of these
things that the China is now focused on
and from your own work what are the ways
in which China is like harnessing this
cyber power well what they've done is
pretty much everything they could have
done I think I heard Carrie Gracie on
the BBC of the other day saying they've
paid their they begged borrowed and
stolen their way to the status that they
are now in and that is of course true
they have sought to acquire by various
legitimate means access to most advanced
US and other Western technologies
through purchases through academic
exchanges through sending students to
study these subjects at US universities
etc etc
they've also unquestionably been
involved in very extensive industrial
scale industrial cyber espionage which
is state-directed they're not
necessarily always undertaken by stains
but we're now moving to an interesting
situation where in the past I think
there appeared to be
a conviction in the United States and
elsewhere that China would be able to
copy but not innovate but they've moved
beyond the copy you know the the cut and
paste strategy now and they're showing
that in many areas they they are able to
innovate and I think particularly where
China has shown innovative capability is
maybe not so much in core scientific and
engineering breakthroughs but in the
application of breakthrough technologies
to provide services that offer
efficiency gains that you know
facilitates daily existence and
eradicate a lot of the friction that
exists particularly in Chinese urban
life developing very innovative
approaches to developing the services in
that area I think China has shown a lot
of innovative capability in terms of
artificial intelligence it's so clear
that which is what we really talking
about here is machine learning China is
still some way behind the United States
in pretty much every area but this kind
of machine learning is basically a
function of computing power x data
volume and of course what China is doing
with its pervasive online systems is
constantly generating huge quantities of
data that potentially act as feedstock
for the development of artificial
intelligence programs so the jury's out
on this one but I think a general
expectation is although China lags the
United States at the moment the the the
likelihood is that they will catch up
pretty quickly and we're used to hearing
the internet talked about as a sort of
global good
do you predict that in the future
perhaps in relation to how the Hawaii
case is being dealt with in a moment do
you think we're seeing a move towards a
like nation state controlled internets
of a fragmented world of Internet or a
more global well then I think it's
probably going to be more the former and
already we're seeing signs of that so
China in particular was an early
exponent of internet sovereignty by
which it meant near the ability of the
state to control the content that was
transiting China's physical frontiers
and that was relatively easy to do
because China has for a country its size
extremely few internet international
internet access points very very easy to
get across those and control the flow a
lot of other authoritarian states have
been attracted to this approach
precisely because they see external
ideas as a dangerous challenge to the
regime narrative whatever that is and
that that is a model that is gaining
acceptance in parts of the world we're
seeing now Russia although configured
very differently from China in terms of
internet access points is also trying to
you know bring information in within the
purview of the Russian state if you look
at the Chinese internet it is already a
very distinct ecosystem from the
internet that you and I more habitually
inhabit and utilize you know it really
is it's almost as if you know one has
gone to Mars and found in intelligence
and highly advanced civilization but
doing things rather differently from
from the way that we do and I think that
there is particularly now that there
there is this major standoff between the
United States and China
over the pursuit of technology dominance
in the 21st century I fear that the risk
of a kind of internet bifurcation you
know the evolution into two distinct
systems is a bigger I mean I've been
talking about this for four years as a
possibility but it's looking more like a
possible outcome then I would previously
have thought and what would this look
like would this be result of a cyber war
cyber crisis no not necessarily I think
it would be a consequence of two
different systems going their own way
and in effect you would have a global
internet that was subject to border
controls it's more like that I mean
slightly we talk about cyber conflict
cyber war as if it was something akin to
a kinetic war you know a kind of
exchange of ordnance and armaments in
fact what we've got between these two
competing systems already is a kind of
constant contest station between states
within the cyber domain this is
happening 24/7
everybody's at it the United States has
just come up with this new strategy
called persistent engagement for dealing
with adversaries in the cyber domain
which essentially says you know we're
not going to put up with this anymore
we're going to strike back and whatever
and we're going to do it on on a
continuing you know and incessant basis
which really only
codifies a situation that's been in
existence for 20-plus years already
have you seen we've like we've talked a
lot about war or crisis but have you
seen steps towards something that could
create cyber peace or is there like
structures and which would have to be in
place for this to happen well I mean the
cyber domain is a huge domain and you
have to break it down into many
component parts and the idea that you
can't have one kind of overarching
process that would be able to get its
arms around everything and come to some
sort of globally meaningful conclusion
is I think unrealistic I think what
you've got to do is work in you know the
different sectors and try to aggregate
that up to some broad principles which
can be agreed by all parties a lot of
work is going on doing that I mean one
of the things that I am have been
involved in for the last two years is
called the global Commission for the
stability of cyberspace which has been
funded by a number of governments and
with some private sector involvement
looking at the challenges to the
stability of cyberspace by what
effectively mean we mean the reliable
reliable access to in Internet that we
can trust the you know the the number of
challenges to that situation are high
and rising as we see for example States
increasingly involved in exploits that
involve attacking the domain name system
which is the nearest thing to the the
backbone of the global Internet so
that's just one small example of a lot
of initiatives that are taking place at
different levels at a government level
at an international level through the
United Nations the United Nations
secretary-general Guterres himself with
a background in cybernetic engineering
is very very in
and concerned about this we've had
exercises going on for a number of years
looking at issues of cyber security
under the aegis of the United Nations
first committee which is about peace and
security the so called governmental
group of experts I mean I know there are
lots of governmental groups of experts
under the United Nations but this one is
the only one that deals with
cybersecurity issues we've now got two
processes under the UN first committee
dealing with cybersecurity and they kind
of you know potentially at odds with
each other but plans are afoot to try
and make them work together but unless
and until States can be and it's
particularly true for states can be
persuaded that the costs of carrying on
as we are now will in a long term exceed
the likely benefits I think this is
going to be a very tough ask to deliver
on and that's before we get to issues
like pervasive cybersecurity a criminal
cyber malign activity which is growing
almost exponentially for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI
TV
you